なんかぱっと見
本田圭佑だよね
ああ
(笑)
シャトルイート！！
というわけでつる兄！！
はい！
お前がやっていた動画を
俺は丸パクリさせていただく！
いいですよ！！
いいの？
やっちゃってください！
でも聞いたとき、まじで俺はやりたいと思った
みなさん、シャトルランはご存知でしょうか
どぉれみぃふぁそぉらぁしぃどぉ
っていう
１オクターブ音が上がる間に　端から端までぇ？
いくっていう
シャトルランって分かりますよね？でも
いや分かると思いますよ
あのドシラソファミレド～ドシラソファミレド　何回、体力の限界まで往復できるかってゆうのが
あるんですけどもぉ、シャトルイートはそれの食べる版でございます！
ｗｗｗｗ
馬鹿ですね
いや、でもやったんでしょ？
何回でした？
僕はー…
（パシッ！）
貴方の友達の記録は16本でした
なんかそれだけ聞くと
めちゃくちゃ
弱そうだなって思っちゃう。
いやーきついっすよ
要するにドレミファソラシドって終わるまでに食っちゃえばいいんでしょ？
そうなんすよ
飲み物はあり？
ありで
あと何？くちにくわえればいいの？
はい。
ドレミファソラシドが終わるまでに
口の中にはいればOKです
なるほど、ぜんぶ？
ぜんぶです
ｗｗｗｗ
まあ俺はとりあえず16は越せるくらいちょっと頑張ってみようかなって思います
いや期待大です
一回ちょっとつる兄でみてみていい？
はい！
どれくらいのものか
せっかくうまい棒もたくさんあるので
じゃあとりあえずやってみましょう!
ではよろしくお願いします
(5秒前)
(3)
(2)
(1)
(スタート)
おーはやいはやい、すごい
あははははwww
いいペース  いいペース
すげぇ
はっははははww
やべ、無くなっちゃう
がんばれ!
まだいける
がんばれ
うわ、きたねぇ
なんか出てきた
がんばれ!
あっはっはw
終了～
汚い、まじで
5にいってなかったから4です。
おめでとうございます。
4ぐらいならさすがにいけると思います。
見て思ったのは、
きつそうだなって思った
50、60くらいまでいったときに
おなじ味すぎるとたぶん飽きちゃうんで
はい、というわけで準備できました。
緊張するなこれ
いや、まじで緊張します、これ
ではいきます
おねがいしやす!
はじめしゃちょーの
シャトルイート
スタート!
(5秒前)
(3)
(2)
(1)
(スタート)
おーすごい すごい すごい
いや、これまじワンチャンあります
これはある
あははははwwww
おーすごい!
w
気合で
お、ははw  すごい
二口
なんかでたw
いけますいけます
おあーすごい!
え、まじすごいっすよ
速くなった
おーwすごい
すごい
お"あ"ー
いや、まだいけます
わーすごい
まじめに
うわやばい、これ越す
すごいww
うわーすごい
これはまじで
ん？
んん？
13、すごい
気合で!気合で。
うはははwすごいw
割った
反則なしで
おー16越え
次いけば記録更新です
あ、やばいやばい
こえたーw
いやぁすごいっす、まじで
口の中が凄いことに
あーーはははww
大変なことに
世界新記録？
新記録です!!
おっしゃー
お"ーーーー
一応なんかこぼれたりしたんすけど
ちゃんとずるしないようにちゃんと食ったんで
正式な世界新記録ではないでしょうか
そうです
おめでとうございます
ぜひ色んなYoutuberさんにも
やってほしいすね
ww
死者でたらおまえのせいだかんな